so let's talk about uh the uh the one
bite
pizza sure schtick so how did this begin
so that began
i i wanna say about five years ago we
had a debate in our office if you could
eat one food the rest of your life what
would it be one of the guys that works
for us said burritos
i think his theory was like breakfast
burritos i said pizza and then we
actually did it
so for about a month i only ate pizza
every single meal
i was eating it so much i like grease
coming on my toes it was cool
but i was eating it so much people start
building how is it and i'm like all
right i'll just take one bite and give
you a quick score
and it just resonated it was obvious it
resonated so
even after the contest ended i continued
to do it we're at boston in boston at
the time
and when i moved to new york i said i'll
just try every single pizza place in new
york
and it's one of those things people
still see me in the street and they'll
just think i'm the pizza guy like they
don't even know i do anything else like
oh there goes the pizza guy
so it is uh probably the single most
popular thing i do
although i have to say that uh i i did
get a kick out of the
my co-religionist spotting you on the
street knowing exactly who you were
uh in fairfax and and one of them uh bar
mitzvahing you on this yeah bar mitzvah
me it was weird timing because he so
that was filmed like weeks before
my sex tape was released and he was
rapping like
it's leather yeah yeah joke i'm like
this looks like a fetish video
it came out the same day so it was set
me up for some bad
bad jokes are you jewish i am okay so
what do your parents think of all this
they haven't talked to me about the most
recent sex tape the first sex
tape is that what you're asking this
yeah yeah i mean yeah i'm not probably
better than that
yeah the first one they asked me uh
whether
my dad he's like did you do this on
purpose are you trying to be like kim
kardashian i'm like are you
crazy uh of course not um but
you know they've come to roll with the
punches i think
my dad was the type of guy he he'd send
me uh
if he saw a story on the internet he'd
fax it to me
so he he was not necessarily the most
savvy tech guy
but it took him a while to realize hey
this thing is working barstool
they're proud but occasionally sex tape
will be collateral damage to having you
be successful i guess
so are you concerned i mean i sort of
asked this earlier but are you concerned
that as the culture decides that jokes
are forbidden
that that's going to be bad for your
business or you think it's going to
provide an opportunity to open wider
well i don't know that that's going to
continue you know trump broke so many
people's brains
i'm curious to see what the next couple
years are like because i he just had
people
like everybody who complained about
something we a joke we made
and this isn't 99.9 of the time
this was 100 time if i looked at their
twitter profile it was political
underneath what they said about me
it was politics 100 of the time
so maybe that goes away and opens up the
flip side is
there is an audience that appreciates
and it's not even left or right it's
kind of both
like i like how these guys aren't
backing down um and our audience allows
us to do that
so people have always asked why do you
fight back or why do you push back
or why just shut up when someone takes a
shot at you that you feel is unfair
it's like i'm not gonna do that like i i
will never throw
the first punch but if you throw a shot
at me on twitter
out of the clouds it's not my
responsibility to protect you
i i don't feel that way i haven't felt
that way since day one and i don't feel
it now
but that's what all these people do
they'll throw grenades
and then they'll cry when you're like
well we're shooting back now
it's like why'd you throw the grenade so
and i've offered this is i know it's
kind of cliche
i'll talk to anybody if you have a
problem with me i'll talk to you anytime
anyplace anywhere
you can bring a hundred people and i'll
debate you by myself
because i'm confident now are there
jokes i've made that i wish i didn't and
are
perceived differently now of course but
i've been doing this for 20 years
so i'll go through point by point by
point everything i've ever said and done
so am i maybe i wish i could do that but
i know my character
and our intent has always been to make
people laugh period
so you mentioned trump and obviously
trump has been the political
400 pound gorilla in the room 800 pound
gorilla in the room for
for a while here so what did you make of
of trump and what was it like
interviewing him
that was surreal interviewing him
because i've never interviewed anybody
before so
you know i found out they asked me to do
it the day before
it's like all right yeah cool i'm gonna
go to the white house and do it great
um he was super nice to me uh
and you know i thought there's an
element of
my personality and he got it he gets
attacked so much probably that his
hackles go out
and almost like what i just said oh
you're going to attack me i'm going to
be a real jerk back to you
now is it always presidential probably
not there's things he did
that i like and i think he's so unusual
and then there's things he did
where it's like ugh that makes it hard
for me
to support him and like the
charlottesville riots when he's like
there's bad people on both sides
to me it's like yeah that was like the
kkk you gotta like say that and
be more open to that i think the way he
handled the capital
was really bad so there's things he did
that really bad
but again it's so two-sided on every
like the the democrats being like let's
all get along now and
you got to support the president's like
well you didn't do that so why should
they do that
so it just sucks both sides suck um
but he's not a black and white guy
that's for sure and i do think
he he knew what he was doing
most of the time so you know if he's
going into a state where he thinks he
can say things that gets his base behind
him
he'll do it he's not dumb he's doing it
but does it help
unity and things like that probably not
so you guys are still located in new
york
is that going to be for the long haul
considering which way new york is going
right now
i don't know i mean where are we going
to go massachusetts
which isn't probably much better like
tax wise so we're an east coast company
or an east coast grind like
down here in florida man what are you
doing no i couldn't take my company here
i'm going to be here but i got a young
company
and to see my guys strolling down south
beach at 4 00 a.m like
that we won't have to worry about taxes
because we won't be making any money so
we got to find that balance and what do
you think is the future of sports
because what we've seen over the past
few years
is the viewership on sports is just
hitting the skids i mean it's really
really bad except for you know maybe mma
which continues to do
really really well i think in part
because dana white runs his company
kind of like you run your company or in
my company he's just like you know this
is my company i'm doing exactly whatever
the hell i want and if you're gonna like
it you can shove it
but all these other big kind of sporting
conglomerates nfl nba mlb
they seemed like they were in growth
mode some of them nfl and nba
particularly
five years ago but it seems like now
they are running into some real
headwinds
what do you think is the future of
sports here it's hard to say you know i
i
and it's hard to actually in my mind
pull out necessarily what's happening
like e-gaming for example people grow up
the kids nowadays are doing different
things like i used to go play wiffle
ball and baseball every day now people
are playing video games
and that's a world that's exploring tick
tock and things like that the kids
they're making videos of dancing in
front of mirrors they're not doing
traditional things and i think that
effect
plays out on ratings and things like
that
i really don't know i i mean i think the
sports will be around football's got a
little bit of probably an issue
with like not only whether it be
political stuff but actual like
concussions and things of that nature
and taking hitting out of the game
i don't know i think i think it really
varies sports and sport but
i couldn't imagine a world where they're
not here let's say you have 100 bucks
you got to put it on a sport
and this is the sport that's the growth
sport for the next 10 15 years which one
you put it on
nba i think they have the best
commissioner
the nba uh obviously like a lot of other
sports they took a hit over the last
year got very very political and now
obviously there are a lot of critics
people like me i'm very critical of the
nba i make no bones about this
you know you got major players in the
nba who are spending
you know all day talking about the how
much america is a systemically racist
country while pulling down 50 million
dollars a year
we're talking about wage differentials
well women in the nba are making 215
grand a year and they're making 49
million dollars a year
hype effect i mean hypocritical lebron's
like the all time with like they're in
their stances on china and what goes on
so i agree with that
but i think they got the best
commissioner and i think they're most
uh internet savvy did you know that
every like on this video creates one
additional
leftist tear gleaming in the sunshine
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button